i want to bring you some breaking news  now coming to us from lancashire police  in connection with the search for  missing  katie kenyon 33 year old mother of two  the police say they have sadly  found the body of a woman the discovery  was made last night in an area  uh as part of the forest of boland after  receiving new information and at this  stage they say they're not in a position  to formally confirm the woman's bod  identity but they do believe that the  body is that of katie her family have  been told and they continue to be  supported by specially trained officers  so a body has been found in the search  for missing katie kenyon andrew burfield  who's 50 and of burnley has been charged  with her murder  you